so thirty years since the Central Park
five happened we're actually looking
over the park right now where we are do
you think this could happen today oh I
know it could yeah
definitely could we're looking at cases
all over the country where people have
been harmed by the presumption of
criminality because of who they are the
way they look the economic status where
they live so this is definitely
something that's top of mind for me
because it's highly probable that it's
happening somewhere in the country right
now yeah it's sad it's still like we're
still dealing with this stuff and it's
not really changing yeah now Greek has
some of my favorite actors are in this
of course Felicity Huffman is in this I
know her other project with Netflix got
delayed the release got delayed because
she pled guilty the college admissions
scam was there any apprehension it was
their conversation about should we delay
this and there's no way no was there any
like worry about that that would be a
distraction my focus is on the very real
harsh heartbreaking realities of five
black and brown men who endured a great
pain and a great tragedy and I would
appreciate a cue from the focus on that
yeah no absolutely now there's gonna be
people that watch this that don't know
about the Central Park five so what do
you hope that people get out of it that
don't know about this at all
well it's a primer it's taking you from
end to end so over a course of 30 years
that this tracks you're able to see this
whole very famous case but while you're
watching it you are learning a lot about
the American criminal justice system and
all of the ways that it works and does
not work overwhelmingly does not work
and so the hope is that people can watch
it on two levels they can watch it and
kind of consume this this this case that
has all these twists and turns but then
also understand what it is like to be a
young black and brown man to be arrested
to be accused to be a to go through the
trial process the bail process
incarceration post incarceration and
these are all these levels or the levers
of the criminal justice system that
enough people don't know about their tax
dollars go to in this country and yet
they they barely know what it is so the
hope is to illuminate that for folks and
the five Ewing actors have talked to
them earlier and they were just so
appreciative about the real guys were on
set how important was that to have their
involvement in this
to set as well I think it was important
for the actors there because it raised
the stakes you know they remembered wow
this is a real person I have the honor
to play them this is a man who's gone
through a traumatic experience
and his family I need to honor that so I
think it really affected the
performances in the best way I think you
can see in the performances that the
actors were all in and the presence of
the real people contributed to that yeah
I know you did tweet a couple weeks ago
kind of marking the anniversary of Trump
you know putting that ad in the papers
of course Trump Tower actually looks
over such a park do you hope he watches
this Oh like is there yeah there's
nowhere to change that perspective in
any kind of way yes my head just does
not project changing the perspective of
people who after 30 years and after
these men have been exonerated and even
the evidence has come out that it was
not them who's still cling to the racist
biased unreasonable and irrational
belief that they did it
you know if 30 years and all of that
can't change your mind I can't and I'm
not interested in doing that we want to
share it with people who are
forward-thinking
who have open minds and hearts and who
are interested in understanding how it
happened so it can never happen again
that's very well said congratulations
thank you
you